on était retour du festival
interceltique à lorient on avait tous un
peu picolé et le conducteur s'est
endormi
vu qu'on a tapé un séparateur de voix on
a fait quelques tonneaux
on s'est retrouvé sur le dos de la
voiture et là il ya deux voitures qui
nous est rentré dedans côté passager
donc j'étais situé en fait le projet
aucun souvenir donc je me suis réveillé
à l'hôpital
j'ai mon appartement
vivez tout seul visitez cuisinier en cdi
je travaille dans un restaurant qu'à
parler et on prévoit j'aimais bien
amusés dans ses week-ends faire un peu
la fête quoi c'est à dire que j'ai
récupéré au niveau des bras mais j'ai
pas en fait la fonction de mes mains
donc j'ai la sensibilité à peu près
jusqu'au niveau des pecs et après tout
le reste j'ai aucune possibilité
avis après sept ans pour l'instant je
n'ai pas encore vu ce que je suis encore
dans le centre de rééducation sur la
recherche dans l'appartement
donc j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion de
vivre en dehors de kerpape à part les
week-ends donc ici à kerpape par la
rééducation les loisirs à côté tu sens
fait pas grand chose donc j'ai pas
encore
j'ai pas encore une autre vie après
l'accident que j'ai pas encore eu magie
encore rappelé
j'ai perdu pas mal d'amis donc j'ai
et lors de mes amis venant seront à
kerpape c'est des personnes comme moi
qui sont en fauteuil roulant qui sont
handicapées mais mes amis d'avant je les
voie moi c'est sûr où les voit plus du
tout mais j'ai beaucoup moins navigant
et moi je me suis fait quoi
qu'il faut faire attention sa route pour
fois agen ou avec de l'alcool